Hi, and welcome back to another
VC libraries Open code review.
I'm Stephanie Lawhead,
a visual C plus libraries developer.
And today we'll be looking at PR 3035,
adding stood view zip from a
new contributor, Tyler Brawl.
So this is 1000 line PR, 1311 lines,
but it's entirely adding new code,
not changing existing code.
I'll be doing the final review of it,
and Nicole has already reviewed this.
For correctness. Uh.
Now, I have not looked deeply into um,
stood zip. Uh.
The committee has been adding all
this range of stuff to C + 23,
so I'm vaguely aware of what it does,
but I'll be looking at the
standards for the first time.
So this describes.
This nice detailed description
that Tyler has provided.
Explains that this is a
partial feature implementation,
so it's not completely implementing
the paper, but only stood view. Zip.
The paper also adds a stood view.
Transform, which we won't be seeing today,
but it may come in a future follow up PR.
So let me open up the tracking issue.
Because this is a partial PR.
This means that we will not be
getting the feature test macro.
Because our policy is that we only
define a feature test macro when a
feature is complete and non buggy
enough to actually be usable on,
there's something as locked
by like severe compiler bugs.
For example,
we will refrain from defining
the feature test macro until.
Um, it is useful,
so we won't be having this bit.
Um,
there are a couple of LWG
issues that affect this.
One is implemented.
1 is not,
because it affects zip transform,
and there's a couple overlapping patch
papers that do modify stood zip.
So we're going to need to
open up all this stuff.
This is the primary paper.
And then the library issues we need
to look at are this one and this one.
OK.
And this has all been added to the
latest working paper and 4917,
so I'll actually probably be
referring to that because the code
has been passed extensively or the
specification has been patched extensively.
OK,
so this should be easier because
it's mostly adding new wording
so we don't need to jump around
a bunch of different places.
So, and I think with zip,
the one that we've already gotten,
um, this seems really familiar.
Um, the tuple and pair and
vectorable reference changes from.
Or was that another paper?
I think we already got those.
OK we do already have the tuple
impaired changes from this.
We think Ajang submitted that change.
That's right.
Yeah, so we we merged that a
while ago trying to load all
this state back in my head.
The change log I'm explains all this.
I think if we search for zip,
yeah here we go.
It's shipped,
it's in the current production
release VS 2022173.
So essentially the first part
of the paper is implemented the
tuple pair injectable reference
that affects the existing library.
Um, so this will be the second
of at least three parts.
Um, so here's the zip paper.
So tuple pair, all this stuff is done.
Like go down. OK, so I think we have this.
Is explanations to integer class type.
Common type stuff.
OK, so the new zip stuff is in range dot zip.
That's a stable name.
We're not going to be looking
at zip transform.
And then there's also an
adjacent and adjacent transform.
Um, do we have this? I think no.
According to this description,
does this mention Jason?
No. No. Jason no. OK.
So this is purely just had.
Yeah, we don't have that form
or adjacent or Jason form.
OK.
So we may be seeing several follow-up years.
This is good.
It means there's more bite size.
We only have to look at one section
worth rewarding.
OK.
I'm just checking here to see if there's
other edits that range zipped it outside.
I'm almost certain that it's not.
Lots of effects equivalent
to stuff a Sentinel.
OK,
so now I'm going to close this
paper and I'm just going to
look at what's in the standard.
Let me look at LWG issue.
This is also updating a spaceship
standard ease again in rain zip iterator.
OK,
so this is already been
applied to the working paper.
And this is the compatibility paper.
Scroll down. Wording to this effect.
OK, so tuple this is already been.
Taking care of tuple like.
Yep, Yep, Yep.
Infection with two bowl quality for
tuple common reference specialization.
I can remember if we got this.
Hair stuff let me scroll faster.
This also edits zip transform no.
At least not up there.
Sensitive containers.
OK, did get rid of a pair like concept.
They've modified elements view.
OK, so did change zip view.
OK, so looking at the current
working paper will give us all that.
OK, great.
So now let's look for ranges.
Zip.
Did I search long stable name
probably. Arranges library.
OK here we go zip view range dot zip.
Silly me. OK. And OK,
we got everything here.
OK, so let's actually look at the code.
And see if I can do side by side.
Find. There we go.
OK. So I want to minimize this real
quick to see what we're looking at.
OK, most of the changes are to ranges about
500 lines changes to our central Internet
arrivals core and then adding a new test.
OK, I like to start easy, we're adding.
One new test directory,
correctly spelled, uh, the paper number.
I'm just going to check the title
here because I think that's right,
2321R2232 one R2.
This is the same paper number,
but this one is view zip correctly sorted.
Yep, that looks good.
So the test will be running in the internal
harness or we got a configuration here?
OK, so this one's a little custom.
Interesting.
Uh, we've got our banner, which is good.
OK, so we've got a note here.
Note zip view under score capital
Iterator defines area overloads for ITER,
swap and inter move,
so the test fails to compile
unless permissive minus is set,
so it needs strict mode.
This issue isn't unique to zip view,
all the types whose iterators
define overloads for these
functions have this requirement.
OK, so this is justifying why
we've got the strict matrix
strict meaning permissive minus.
This is, uh, uh, something that um, uh.
Ideally we could just enforce
strictness all the time, but um,
because some legacy programs don't
exactly follow the standard.
We are supporting the permissive mode,
including in C + 20 and C + 23 mode,
even though it would be nice
if we didn't have to.
And that's why most of our tests try to
compile with the usual latest matrix,
which means compile in 23 mode and
throw in a permissive configuration.
But if something absolutely
cannot tolerate permissive,
then we set the strict option and we
have a matrix of options for that.
So that's what this is.
So we're going to use the strict
and ranges requires concepts.
Latest means it's a 23 feature matrix,
that's a correct, and then we're crossing it.
So we're actually run this test four
different. Times with test input,
bidirectional, forward and random.
It's very interesting.
OK, I'm going to see why we need this.
I'll remember that.
But this is good.
OK, I'm going to briefly look at the test.
OK, good. We got our banner.
OK, we'll see what this test does.
I'll come back.
This is definitely unnecessary here also
because we're silencing that cling warning.
OK, so let's work our way towards the
product code center internal header.
So here's a citation for the 2165R4.
Now this one,
this was just a patch paper.
Did we have a top level?
Did we have a tracking issue for this?
C.
Half the half the work here is just,
um, information management, OK.
So we actually do have a
tracking issue for this.
So we do consider a top level
feature and I guess we're
implementing incrementally.
OK, so this is the correct
cleaned up name and spelling.
Yep. Is it correctly sorted to
1321652 and six six?
Yes it is compatibility between
two parent black objects.
And then we have a explanation.
Changes to view zip only. OK, good.
And then zip paper, previously we
said it's pair tuple and vector bool.
And now we're going to flip it
and say what we're missing.
Missing view. Zip transform.
Views adjacent and views adjacent transform.
Yep, 3 views. That's right.
We've got that Oxford comment there.
Perfect.
We're not defining feature just macro yet.
So no change to the feature test,
macro test.
OK, perfect.
So let's look at the product code.
OK. Ranges is including algorithm.
This algorithm include ranges. Let's check.
Algorithm. Algorithm includes X memory OK.
Don't think that means it includes ranges.
But let's check real quick ink.
OK, ranges is mostly a
leaf header in the STL.
Um, the stack adapter and the queue adapter,
which are definitely leaves for
the purposes of algorithm drag
it in and our internal stuff.
Nothing else includes ranges itself,
so there's no circularity issue here. It is.
Not great from a throughput perspective
that we got to drag an algorithm.
Now in some sense it kind of it
matters less because ranges is already
quite big and the C + 23 modules
which we just implemented make this
issue moot because it's so fast.
But in the classic header world,
there is a throughput impact of dragging.
In all the algorithm algorithm
is 200 something kilobytes.
It's quite large.
I'm assuming OK actually,
I'm not sure why we need this.
Uh, what are we calling here?
Be stood something,
something student focus from
type traits that can't be it.
Same with stud apply.
What does it need? Yeah.
Deco, Val. Yeah. Yeah.
That's all we got yet.
I don't see any use of algorithm
assuming that it would be a call
to a non ugly function. Just apply.
That's all tuple stuff.
I don't think this is necessary,
or if it is, I'm missing something.
We have it. We have test coverage.
We have a test called include each other
alone that we've had running for over
a decade that make sure we can include
each header from the STL in isolation
so we can't accidentally use stuff,
at least in a way that explodes
if you never call anything.
So I'm not too worried about snipping out
and include that we're actually are using,
but it sure doesn't look from this
brief scan like we're using it.
I'm going to recommend that we or
I'm gonna ask why we're using it.
Let's see, did Nicole ask?
Maybe they thought they ohh yeah this did.
This did come up. Yeah it was.
Range is Max.
Ah, that's interesting. Um.
Do we need the ranges version of Max?
Yeah, our contributor here mentioned that.
Yeah, I think this is still an issue.
I I don't like the included algorithm,
um, just because it's so big.
OK, so where's the use of Max?
Now it would be parenthesized
because of horribleness.
We're maxing on an initializer list.
And I'm assuming min is the UM.
OK, 2 uses of men. This one is forming
an initializer list. Yeah, that's.
Those are pretty small algorithms.
I mean relatively speaking,
do we only define them in
algorithm and not like X utility?
Uh, this is gonna be.
It's probably the case that ranges Max is
only defined in the algorithm because we
haven't needed it anywhere else before.
Right, the range is 1 by wondering
if we could use classic uh,
that element one is not.
I certainly think so.
It looks like these are just different types,
so they're integer class types.
Or sorry integer like types.
They're integer like types so they
should work OK with stood minute Max.
Let's see, we've got.
OK, these are the two art forms.
We're not using a projection, right?
It's implemented an algorithm.
So even if we call classic.
We haven't needed them before,
but could we promote them as the question?
Ah. Yeah, you're right.
There's no need for a projection or
any of that fancy powerful stuff.
Where is Max?
It's in parens because macros OK,
this calls Max element. Ah.
This is the classic one.
It just happens to occur after the UM.
Range of stuff.
OK, so we call Max Solomon unchecked.
Where's that live?
That lives in algorithm.
OK, it's it's not true.
Ohh, it's nontrivial size because
it also uses our vectorized thing,
Alice Britannia's minmax optimization stuff.
So this is larger than it used to be.
I was mentally thinking,
Oh yeah, that's a tiny algorithm,
but it's actually gotten a lot
fancier and a lot more powerful.
But otherwise it doesn't really have
a lot of dependencies. Interestingly,
we would like to use the vectorized 1.
Here is utility core header.
It's not is it?
Oht is ohh and we had that issue.
All these complexities popping up.
We've got this issue where.
Um, core headers which we try not
to have runtime dependencies. Uh.
If we try to promote a vectorized
algorithm to them, that doesn't work.
We encountered this in another context.
I don't think it was min Max.
It was something else we were
trying to drag up here and we
ended up having to back that out.
I think it was stood equal.
Or something like that.
So attempting to promote the.
Min, Max. Even if it's just the
classic initializer list one up here,
um, that would be a problem.
OK, so this is not it's not a trivial thing.
Um.
Dragging an algorithm is not awesome
for performance for throughput.
But maybe people should just
be using import stud?
Um,
this is something we could
potentially investigate in the future.
The uh. The alternative is code duplication.
Extract a just a very simple hello world,
just the core, not the stuff using the
stood Max or the vectorized version.
That way we wouldn't need to drag
any algorithm, and we could do that
if we really needed throughput.
Range is is I I think Casey is,
um, more familiar with the
throughput ranges ranges.
Throughput is already pretty low,
and I think it's possibly the header you
would notice algorithm released in just
because the denominator is already large.
If algorithm was. Max index utility.
Instead of utility utilities.
Not non core, right? No utilities.
Ohh yeah that's the one that's non core.
Exercise is not core. Yeah, yeah,
this one can use vector arguments just fine.
This is where we put count.
Find this one is reasonable to promote.
Yeah, this is the one step up
for an algorithm spot, right?
Yeah, that's a good point. That's why.
That's why. That's why this exists.
It could do that and then does
ranges already include X utility?
Yes, very very likely.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Because it includes like string view
internal indirectly from somewhere.
But yeah, certainly includes ex utility.
Yeah, that's interesting.
Um.
Most I'm just thinking of the logistics
because we've got that tool set up,
tool set update I'm working on today
that makes some large scale code
movement very obnoxious because
it's reformatting a bunch of code.
Aside from that, I see no reason why
we couldn't promote this to X utility
and then ranges wouldn't need it.
Let's see, should I comment that and
then say hold off on actually doing
anything there until at least the tool set
updates in and then we can move around code?
Because I would hate for a comment to cause
horrible merge conflicts and wasted work.
Um, the alternative is do this thing
and then file a follow-up issue to
go improve the throughput later.
As much as Clang format has
changed everything in ranges,
I think this PR is going to have
terrible merge conflicts anyway.
Yeah, but making it worse.
Not be that big of a deal.
Yeah, um. I'll include a comment.
Or should I just resurrect this comment?
The.
Yeah, the IT is the same issue.
So I think we can can resurrect it.
Um, OK, unresolve. OK, um. See,
Casey and I talked about this in the video.
Code review um.
We believe that X utility.
Would be on appropriate place to move the.
Initializer. Say promote um,
vote the classic initializer list.
Uh, actually,
are they both using initializer lists?
Uh, or was one using a non? Unit list,
but just arbitrary range sizes or sizes,
is literally an initializer list,
and the other one we form reform braces,
so in that list would be sufficient.
There's no need for the ranges.
Um, plastic.
Yeah.
No need for the ranges machinery as it is.
Included or as it is, um.
Uh, let's say I wanna say higher up.
That could be confusing.
It's uh. Included by algorithm.
What extra utility?
Yes, this included and is non.
Or, um, we use it.
Decentralize. Yeah, I won't explain.
Yeah, maybe I will explain.
And already centralizes similar algorithms
of wide applicability. They ASL.
Yes. That is non core,
I mean too much parenthetical.
So the vectorization.
Won't be problematic.
Um. Let's see.
Note due to the um.
Pending tool set update
I wanna say it's 3155.
Let's check.
Yes, I remember correctly through and
five number 3155 Yep. Code move movement.
May cause obnoxious
formatting merge conflicts.
I recommend waiting until the
tool set update is merged before.
Attempting to address this. Sir.
OK. I should probably mention
that the throughput impact is.
We should say we agree about
the throughput impact.
A. Share. OK guys.
Concern about the throughput.
Impact of algorithm.
OK. Casey and I talked about this
in the video code review we share.
He will case concern about the
throughput impact of algorithm and
we believe the utility would be an
appropriate place to promote the
classic initializer list overloads.
No need for the range of machinery
as it is included by algorithm and
is non core so the vectorization
won't be problematic and already
centralizes similar algorithms of
wide applicability in the STL.
Note due to the pending tools update
three and five code movement may cause
obnoxious formatting merge conflicts.
Recommend waiting until the tool
set update is merged before
attempting to address this concern.
OK, we've got one line of
product code reviewed. Port.
OK, so we've got some concepts here.
OK, this is actually kind of annoying.
Let's split that, OK? Yeah.
Minify the this OK, that's readable.
OK, so we are translating over here.
I was going to actually read the
standard and see what's going on.
We take a bunch of views and we get
a view of tuples to references.
So like if you've got a vector of
int and a vector of strings and the
insco 1020 thirty and the strings
say cute fluffy kittens,
then you can get a zip view that will
give you tuples of references to 10 cute 20,
fluffy 30 kittens.
And then you can go feed those to
some algorithm or something and
then use it as customization point
object that does that.
OK,
one other thing that I want to be on
the lookout for is usage of export.
Because we have merged standard
library modules,
we need to make sure that every
public name is marked with our
internal export stood macro because
forgetting that will not immediately
cause any problems but is a bug.
Eventually this becomes second nature to us,
but for now we need to make sure
that we check this. OK, so.
Exposition only concept does not
get exported.
Let's switch to highlight here, OK?
O we've got template class R's.
These are under score capital range types.
We've got a concept called zip is common,
which is exposition only.
And it's going to be true when the
size of dot, the range types is 1.
And common range of the R's and dot A dot,
so they're all common ranges.
And then using slash slash to
hard wrap because Clang format.
Which may not be necessary,
but it's OK for now with Clang format 15,
which is better about this or OK
and it's good that the OR operator
is coming at the beginning of line
because that's our convention.
OK, I'm checking to make sure that
everything is parenthesized correctly, not.
That they're not all bidirectional ranges,
so the knot is outside the fold expression.
Good. And they're all common ranges. Or.
They're all random access ranges, and.
They're all sized ranges. OK.
Thanks. Looks good. OK,
then we have a tuple transform closure.
This is not depicted in
standard ease up here at least.
Is there anything else I can look for?
People transform OK,
perhaps that's elsewhere.
Search. What is this tuple transform
thing? I'm just being mentioned.
Lots of equivalent twos.
Did it already wrap? Come on.
Here we go, range adapter helpers.
OK, uh. Expedition only.
Let's see, this is making a 2 bowl.
Ohh, I see tuple transform is
apply the tuple transform closure.
Is just the Lambda OK?
OK, so that's what this is, um.
OK, so we've got.
What the callback type? I guess that's F.
OK, this just calls it off here.
I'm thinking should this be
named pollable type or anything?
I'm OK with callback type.
We do pass it to invoke,
so really it is a callable type. Um, the.
The issue here is that in the STL,
especially when overhauling
invoke and stood function,
all that we try to be very
careful about terminology.
If something's passed to invoke and
it goes through the invoke protocol,
the standard formally refers to
that thing as a callable type,
meaning there could be a pointer to
member function or pointer to member
data in addition to something like a
Lambda function or function object,
and it is callable through some generalized.
Syntax.
So we tried to be very careful about
saying that if this is like function type,
I would definitely ask for change.
I'm OK with callback type here,
it's not user visible.
OK, so template on class callback type.
This has to be constexpr.
This should really be no discard,
it's internal. Um.
It's not absolutely necessary.
I feel like it should be
noticed card at least this one.
There's very low risk of us calling this
thing and dropping it on the floor.
I don't know if this merits a comment.
First, I'm wondering if tuple
transform and the others here.
Need to be marked.
Usually with internal helpers
we do want to mark them, um,
because why would you call
this if you don't return it?
Yeah, we always return this stuff.
I'd say it's fairly low risk.
Um, I won't ask for no discard here.
I will think about it
for the public functions.
OK, so going back here,
tuple transform closure
is just making the Lambda.
Probably because defining this
Lambda is pretty obnoxious,
so we want to centralize it.
OK, so template constexpr
auto tuple transform closure.
We take a callback by lvalue reference.
OK. We are no except because we only
store a reference to the callback.
So we're not actually copying anything,
so we can guarantee that we
aren't throwing exceptions.
OK, so we're going to return.
We instead of just using a capture default,
we name ref callback and this is a
generic Lambda so we're templated
on class dot view tuple types.
In place of teas we take teas
refresh data dot view tuples.
OK so that's this so far here.
And then we return.
We make a tuple of the invoke result T.
Here we've got to check that the
types are exactly being mentioned,
because the value category and CV
qualifiers can influence the result.
The callback type ref.
And view tuple types dot Yep, that's good.
And then we're calling it with.
Or constructing this from the result
of student voke. The callback.
And then stood forward view tuple tisu
tuples dot. OK, that's all good. So my.
OK, so that's essentially this here,
but not the apply that's elsewhere.
And then this is the alley call
template on class under score capital
callback type class and our tuple
type constexpr auto tuple transform.
OK,
this takes by perfect forwarding
a callback type ref ref callback.
So that's matching this concept for
auto tuple transform that's depicted as
FFRF and then tuple type refresh under tuple.
Here we're strengthening.
This being commented,
is strengthened even though it's
not actually a standard function.
But because it's depicted in the
standard as exposition only,
I think it's reasonable to have
strength and comment here.
We're no except if this is no
except still apply.
So it's just gonna be the bodies to apply.
Yeah, then all matches.
So we're going to return stood apply
to avoid ADL of make that closure,
and then stood forward tuple type tuple.
OK correct.
OK, so that's this thing done,
and then we've got a tuple for
each same structure,
where we've got one helper to make the
Lambda and then another to actually.
Apply it so template callback type
because it's for auto tuple for each closure.
And take by L value ref callback.
This one's always no except because
we only capture a ref return.
OK,
so now this is the stuff capture
roughed callback view tuple types.
Take that ref ref view tuples.
The Lambda itself could. Row.
So it definitely should not be
no except or anything.
Um.
Here we are casting the result
to void because we don't want to
invoke any sort of overloaded comma,
which is good.
So we call stud invoke of the
callback and then stood forward
view tuple types view tuples.
And then? What is going on here?
This parenthesis is not actually necessary
because what else could the void bind to?
It's not wrong. It might
help visually parsing it.
I don't think I'll complain.
I'm trying to be a little bit
less than a picky in my comments.
And here are the the extra
parent is not the worst.
This is already pretty complicated
expression, so I won't grind my teeth.
If there's an extra parent here,
it's unusual enough that I'm OK with it.
Then comma dot OK, so that's good.
Very, very like the attention to detail that,
um, the standard doesn't bother
to avoid overloaded comma here,
but we need to according to our policies,
and a strict reading of the standard does
indicate that that's correct step forward.
OK, very semi good.
And then two before each is the whole thing.
Template callback type tuple
type context for voyage tuple.
For each I'm checking.
All the names are ugly and they are, um,
public type reference callback tuple,
type reference tuple.
We're gonna accept.
If this is no exception,
apply for each closure tuple type.
Again, it's marked to strengthen.
That's fine. And then we just dropped
the return value on the floor.
No need to cast because to apply is not um.
No discard. OK, that's good.
So we've got the tuple for each.
Uh, close enough. Now we've got helpers.
OK, let's go back to zip view.
Range dot zip as we discovered.
I want the whole stable name.
This will cooperate.
Come on.
There we go.
OK, this is not depicting
an all random access,
but I'm guessing it's going to come up here.
Yeah, and would that maybe can't stuff.
OK. So what are we doing here?
Again, internal machinery template on
bool is constant class dot views concept.
All random access is. Old expression.
How do we ever live without them?
Random access range may be constant, so we
applied the maybe constant constant views.
OK. All bidirectional is bidirectional range
blah, all forward is forward range blah.
OK, that seems reasonable.
Next stop. OK,
another helper zip gets smallest distance.
Is this depicted in the standard?
Ohh and looking here, this is from iterator.
OK so we can highlight this because
it's done all random access.
Yep, that's that. Maybe consed.
Maybe cons, maybe cons?
Yep, exactly find the standard names.
Let's see,
does it have a zip get smallest distance?
Likely this here.
And there are some maximum stuff here.
OK, where exactly is this called?
It's called in the minus of iterators,
which is in fact what I'm looking at here.
This is ITER minus enter.
Where is the generator minus sitter?
No, I'm looking at Sentinel here.
Getter minus sitter.
Here we go. This stuff. OK.
So let's go back up to the definition.
OK, so what's happening here?
Um template class under score
result type class dot allahs tuple
types plus dot rohs tuple types?
OK. And this is constrained to
exist only when the size of
the tuple types are the same.
I'm not sure that this
constraint is necessary.
This is only needed when general.
You only need constraints to
disambiguate overload resolution.
If this simply.
If we can structurally guarantee
that this is only called with
identically sized tuples,
then really this could be a
static cert instead of requires.
In the olden days with um.
When our only machinery was
like spine with Enable, if,
I would absolutely ask, yeah,
there should be a stack.
Assert concepts are not as
egregious as enable if and.
It's still not conventional to use
this when a stack cert would suffice.
But it's not completely wacky.
I would be OK with this. I wouldn't.
I wouldn't have written it like
this myself, but I don't view
this as inherently objectionable.
And perhaps someday it may
even become good style.
Just say, hey, you know, list your
requirements up front rather than just
assuming stuff in static asserting.
If it goes wrong,
I could see an argument for that.
I kind of think the static assert
is cheaper in terms of throughput,
but if it's not overloaded,
I think it's about the
same throughput anyways.
OK I I'll leave this for now.
I'm not gonna not gonna
comment on that. Of course,
because doesn't really user impact.
OK, so this helper is marked no discard.
That's interesting that the
previous helpers were not.
Slightly inconsistent,
but at least this whole group
was marked and this is marked.
OK, I'll get this so it's
not scarred constexpr.
OK, so we explicitly specify the result type.
Probably because we have to
determine or use different type.
Whatever zip gets smallest distance,
we take cons tuple of stuff, LHHS tuple,
cons tuple of right stuff ref RCHS tuple.
This is not strengthened in any way.
But neither is the operator
minus required to be.
Does anybody calling this strengthened
because we need to make sure at all levels.
Ah. Look at this.
So operator minus is strengthened to be.
I'm no except if this is no except
what happens if we call zip get
smallest distance but then zip gets
smallest distance is never marked.
So this is identical to noexcept faults.
So this is an issue.
If we're going to strengthen
here we gotta strengthen this.
OK so now it's time for comment.
Ohh wait no sorry wow, I can't parse this.
It's hiding down here in this.
I missed it because this claim form
it off looked like it was a body,
but it's actually strengthened.
OK, so it is strength.
So we're fine. OK, false alarm.
Uh OK, so we take two tuples.
Uh, suppress claim format.
Probably because it was
dealing with this horribly.
Um, interesting.
We're we're no except if fold expression.
Which is why we've got that
extra layer parents here.
OK, so all of these things
have got to be no except,
um.
Standfast result type of Astrid deck
Oval concelhos tuple type siraf minus
two deck Oval contr tuple type surf.
So it's asking if we pairwise subtract
each of these left minus right,
left minus right,
over and over are all those
expressions now except.
OK, that is correct.
Assuming that's what we're gonna do here.
Um, OK, I see.
Casey,
would you like to contribute
something to the class?
I I would like to suggest that we use
the names of the parameters instead of
calling stood decal Val to get things
of this type and and value category.
But then we would need get and we
would need index because these
are the elements of the tuples
and we've got to crack them open.
How would you phrase it?
With the parameters,
ohh OK, we don't have any.
We don't have an integer sequence here.
I was missing that. Never mind.
OK.
In general, definitely a good good question.
Um, because if we could just
mention the parameter names,
then that's simpler.
But here we actually do need this
complicated full expression.
OK,
I can already see that we've got
some stood qualified size T,
which we should just not qualify
at all because we're within stood.
The two occurrences of stood size T
here should simply be unqualified
as we're within stood,
so we'll always find the type def.
Beth. No addl concerns.
Uh, the two occurrences of size T
here should simply be unqualified
as we as we're within stood,
so we'll always find the type def.
No addl concerns.
OK, Um, wow claim format like.
It's really not having a good day here.
Hopefully 15 handles this better.
OK, so we're going to have a constant
auto get smallest distance closure.
That's a Lambda that captures
the tuples by ref, and it is.
Templated. Interesting.
On a pack of stuff.
Science, T first, edx.
I don't know why this is
commented out as default 0.
We don't pass anything here.
I'm really confused as
to what's going on here.
There's only two occurrences.
We always just give it index
sequence for we deduce.
I I don't see why we
need this comment at all.
It it it's not like it's been declared
elsewhere to be defaulted to 0.
If index sequence is empty then.
I'm assuming we can't call this at all.
This assumes that there's at
least one that's interesting.
Does this have a?
Does does this have trouble if
we are attempting to zip nothing?
I'm not even sure if that's well formed, um.
But that's the first question I
have when I see something cracking
open a pack of types and then
assuming that there's always one um.
OK, so I think the comment should be there.
Then there's a question of what
happens if this stuff is emptied.
Requirements. OK, wonderful.
OK, but I think this comment
should not be here.
Um. Let's see, I uh,
let's ask cause I'm could be
confused rather than saying there's
definitely no reason for this.
And then it turns out there's
a reason and I look silly.
Let's see what's, um,
the purpose of the comment.
Equals zero um.
There appears to be only one
use of get smallest disclosure.
Immediately below.
And it deduces um. 1st.
It exists, so there's no.
Default. Behavior.
OK, what's the purpose of the comment?
Equals zero. There appears to
be only one use of get smallest
distance closure immediately below,
and it deduces first,
so there's no default behavior.
OK, interesting.
We are using tag dispatch because
that's the only way here to get access
to this list of types if CONSTEXPR
has not quite superseded that.
So we take an index sequence.
Uh, first index and then a bunch of indexes.
Ah, OK.
I'm trying to look at what
the first index is used for.
Where is it mentioned?
It's not mentioned.
Oh, it's just. I see.
I see what that equals 0 means. Here.
It's. It's acknowledging that the
sequence will always start with zero
because we're using index sequence 4.
So it's the comment is a reminder that
first it explore absorb the zero and
then the IT exists or one and above
here we just directly hard code zero
to get the first stuff and then we look
at the rest of them with the indexes.
So it's not a default,
it's a reminder of what it is.
That's reasonable.
Um, it's just because I'm reading it
strictly top down that I was confused.
OK, I'll retract my comment.
I found the purpose.
That's pretty thoughtful to have it,
so thank you. Uh OK.
So an equivalence for syndics edx dot dot,
I suppose it could have just been
named like 0, but that's fine.
OK, so what's going on here?
We get a constant result type.
First size is static cast result type.
I've still got 0 OHS.
Minus still get 0 Rohs.
OK, we're always doing left minus right?
OK, if that first size is 0,
so if there are no differences
between the first iterators,
then the smallest is.
Well, you win.
It's zero, we can just short circuit.
Otherwise, maybe some of the other stuff is.
Uh, otherwise we're non 0,
so maybe some of the other stuff
is non zero and we need to.
Subtract now, I'm assuming.
This seems like it's assuming that
none of these will be negative.
How does the operator minus work?
Is it doing some sort of absolute value?
The value with the smallest absolute value.
OK, OK, so if we find 0,
that's by definition the
smallest absolute value,
so that definitely wins.
But if we get nonzero,
whether a little bit bigger than
zero or a little bit less than 0,
maybe we'll find something
at zero later on. OK.
And there's no algorithm that
really short circuits, um.
Interesting that this is not.
We're not taking the absolute
value out of all of these. Um.
It's like doing the subtractions. And then?
That's odd. I'm trying to think
like what happens because I haven't
completely read through this.
Um, what happens if you have a mix
of like negative and positive values?
Some are tiny, some are big.
Is what this is doing,
which is not taking the ABS immediately
equivalent to what the standard says,
which says the smallest absolute value.
Because I would expect to directly
translate the standards to apply ABS,
either call ABS or do it
manually and then find the min.
But this is doing something different.
So this forms an initializer list,
A named one, which is a little bit unusual.
It's not wrong.
It's kind of using it as a container,
which is kind of weird, but not wrong.
Um.
Then what? What do we what? What?
Where are we giving the sizes?
Ohh that it's being given to the ranges? OK.
That could have used an array,
but initializer list is what the
classic algorithm will take.
So here we actually do want that.
OK, constant initializer list
result type sizes is brace
whatever that first size is,
and at this point we know it's nonzero.
And then? A
fold expression, but a pack
expansion of Stuttgart indexes.
Left minus X's right,
over and over and over. OK.
And then we do this odd sort
of absolute value thing if the
first size was negative. Then.
Say we have like negative.
10 then we look for the maximum of
the sizes because we want to find.
The biggest, but this is
assuming everybody's negative.
I don't think that's right because
what if we have a mix of negative
and positive, if we have -, 10.
And then some of the other
differences are like -, 11 negative,
5A billion positive billion then.
The range is Max will find the
positive billion and we'll return that.
But really we should have said
the small staff site value in
this case whatever I said -,
5 absolute and so should be like 5.
Ohh I see it returns the value
with the smallest absolute value.
So if the smallest absolute value.
Or if the value with the
smallest absolute value is -,
5, we should return negative.
We don't absent,
but we do want the smallest one.
We should not return a billion.
I think this is incorrect if we have
a mix of negatives and positives.
I think it was trying to avoid.
Greedily taking the absolute value because
we do need to return the original one,
but I don't think this is
the right way to do it.
In some sense it's like the comparison
should be done with absolute.
We could give it a comparator that
says here's how to compare two values
you absam and then you compare.
But then we can find the minimum
according to that metric and
then return whatever that is.
That would be the right way to do it.
So we would only call min with a predicate.
OK, I think this is a bug.
Unless I'm seriously confused
about how this works.
It sure seems like the ZIP code the
miners should be able to handle it.
Traders being at different positions, um.
But I'm not really sure how.
All these when zipping are they
always marching in lockstep?
But then I would have talked
about the small absolute value.
I I'm I'm confused.
I don't think it's possible to get a
mixture of negative and positive values,
but that's because I don't think it's
possible for the iterator repairs to
ever get out of sync. Right. Right.
Like, I'm trying to figure out,
yeah, why does the standard ease,
why is it trying to handle,
like, you know, you know,
what's the different absolute value?
When I see that, my mind really goes to,
OK, what if they're jumbled,
but if it's like we're doing this thing,
I think all the constituent distances
should be identical and we should be able
to return any of them from this function.
Yeah. I mean, that's how,
that's how a zipper works, right?
So. Yeah. Hmm.
That's really weird.
Is that just a defect in this because of INT?
You know like if some of the different
types are like smaller than, bigger,
but then but then you would run out of
space like when the smallest one runs
out of room for the different type.
Nicole, can you explain?
To us stupid people is uh
is Nicole on the call?
She is not. So we are asking for telepathy.
Um, that's interesting. So. I think.
This does mirror to comment.
The question is, should it be an LWG issue?
Uh, what's going on here? Um.
Sorry, I'm good.
Nicole has explained it in the chat.
Oh, oh, she's in the chat,
just on the call.
Where we have when our
underlying regular common.
The end iterator of the zip view is the
end iterators of all the underlying views.
And if we don't know the size
of those underlying views,
or they're not random access so we can't
grab an arbitrary iterator out of them,
then we don't know that those end iterators
are actually In Sync with each other.
Ohh because you can exhaust some ranges.
Don't know how long the ranges are.
But what happens if you
exhaust ranges before others?
Did you are you were at the end if you
exhaust one of the ranges before the others?
Yeah, the the the end of the zip view is
when the first underlying range it's its end.
OK, but. But in that case,
aren't they still In Sync?
Don't they all still have the same value?
Yes, the iterator values of
that iterator are In Sync, but.
If you want to model common so your zip
view has an end iterator that it returns.
OK, your underlying ranges are all
forward language forward ranges.
They're all say they're forward
common ranges.
Then your zip using iterator
is a tuple of the end iterators
of all the underlying ranges.
But they may have different
lengths so that one that is the
only value out of sync is int.
Ohh weird.
The only way to get an out of sync value.
Out of the design.
Because otherwise,
and that's why the equality comparison
says if any of them compare equal,
they're equal.
Because that way the end iterator
and the end and the yeah sorry,
the iterator you reach by iterating
through the sequence will be equal
to the iterator that end returns.
Just by that,
they have different constituent values,
OK,
because you're considering it
as soon as somebody hit and OK.
That makes sense.
Um.
Yeah, so. OK, so going back here,
this is doing subtraction.
And it's trying to handle the case of.
What if one of these iterators
is like the end iterator?
You have to. Essentially,
the position of it is virtually the
one that's closest to the beginning,
so the smallest absolute value. There are.
That does get the right answer if
you like subtract 2 and iterators,
or if you're end, minus,
begin, or absolute value,
because the left hand argument could be
the end iterator value or the right hand
argument could be the end iterator value.
Yeah, yeah. And you can't have
anything beyond that point,
so you don't need to worry because,
um, if you try to increment increment,
you do stop as soon as one of them hits end.
OK, so there's limited
jumbled Ness permitted,
but can't you still get into the position?
The case I had where you've got like
a small negative and a big positive?
Can't you have that?
No, ohh because they can't be
relatively jumbled like that.
It's either they're all In Sync,
or you are the end iterator
and they're jagged. Right, but.
If you ever have a jagged case that
you'll never advance past the yeah,
so the.
The uh regardless of whether one is
before or afterwards and the jagged case,
they all have the same sign.
It's never possible to have a mix of
negatives and positives in the jagged
case and in the non jagged case.
It's also never possible have a
mix of negative and positives.
OK, so that's that's interesting.
OK, so that indicates this is correct.
Highly non obvious.
OK, so let's read this new eyes.
Uh, constant.
Let's sizes is first size and then get
left minus, get right over and over.
There's no short circuiting if we find a 0,
but we already tried to find
like the case where.
And the thing that the optimization
is reasonable because most of
the time if they're non jagged,
then if the first one zero,
then hey you're equal you return 0.
Otherwise if they're not,
the answer is very very likely nonzero.
It's only for like we're in a jagged case.
You might find a 0,
but we don't really need to optimize that,
so I don't need to worry about short
circuiting. OK, so then return.
If the first size is less than zero,
it's negative.
Then we assume they're all the same sign.
Try to find the maximum of
the remaining sizes,
because that one's going to
be closest to 0 otherwise,
if the first size is.
Not less than zero,
but in this case we know it's
strictly greater 0 because we
already tested for quality.
Then find the minimum of all the sizes.
OK, that is correct.
Agreed.
And then at the end of get smallest
distance return get smallest
distance closure because we need
to expand the pack index sequence
for LHHS tuple types brace,
brace and we've already required.
That they be the same length.
OK, that is.
Reasonable.
OK. And then an equal helper
template on class tuple types.
Class tuple types requires that
the size of LHHS is the size of Rs.
Here I'm making sure that we
don't mix up left and right.
Very very easy. It's no discard.
OK, so consistent with previous
considerable zip iterator Sentinel equal.
OK, so it's not iterator difference, this is.
Are you just equal to a Sentinel?
Um, constituent LSRP LHHS
tuple cons tuple RHS tuple.
This one is. Strengthened.
Not come to this strengthened,
but this one is not exactly
mapping to anything.
In the standards, that's fine.
Um, we're gonna accept if this
package fold expression is no except
um stood deck Oval concelhos ref
equals to Decavalcante RHS ref.
Okay, comparing 2 cost L values,
they all got to be no except OK.
Um constant auto evaluate a
quality closure is capture left
and right tuples by ref.
OK, and then we're gonna go invoke it.
Uh, template on size dot indices.
Take index sequence of indices.
And then just apply is this equal
to that equal still get indices
lehs equals to get indices arhs.
Ah,
and you're equal if any of them are equal.
Because you only need one to hit the end.
OK, so that's why it's more.
OK, so when we actually compute the answer,
we fold over or.
But when we compute no exceptions,
all of them need to be no except.
So we use and there.
Here we're adding the no except.
Here we're using the answers OK,
return to evaluate quality closure on
and index sequence 4 LHHS tuple types
dot brace brace for temporary tag.
Yep, that's good. OK.
Now we can get to the view and
here we have our first export
stood because it is standard.
It's got here.
What's what's cool about export
is that for the range of stuff we
actually need very few of them,
because so much of it is like helper.
Iterators help her Sentinels
operator parent prens,
so we don't need a zillion of them.
It's great.
Turn off Clang format for Clang format 14.
This is OK to keep.
Uh, we'll clean that up later
once we merge with Clint for 15.
Um, OK,
so this is exported because it's
public template on input range.
Data dot view types requires
view view types and data dot,
and the size of dot view types
must be strictly greater than zero.
OK, we have a class zip view.
Dr Publicly because it's a class
from view interface zip view view
types dot turn on. Click format.
OK, private data members.
Uh, no unique address commented out.
Someday it's gonna be cool.
We have a tuple of view types named views.
OK, that's that. Exposition only.
So we got this here.
And then template on Bool
is construct category base.
And I believe that is the Convention
name template Bool is constant.
We specialize requires
if they are all forward.
Assuming that's specified for,
what are we doing iterator here?
Let's see, this is an iterator.
Do you have a specialization?
This one says 40 iterator tag.
Trying to see if there's
two separate standardises.
No, there's not. OK.
Let's talk about Iterator. Category.
I see. OK, yeah, this is this
is implementing. This here. Uh.
But wait, is this is this wrong?
Um. Category base.
Primary and then template bowls cost
requires when they're all forward.
Um, category bases cons using
iterator category input iterator tag.
Um. Iterator category.
Is present if and only if
all forward is modeled.
OK, what is the category?
Is the category input?
OK, category is input so this is correct
even though it doesn't seem like it is OK.
So the category is conditionally input OK.
My brain is like if I see forward here,
this should be forward.
But no, the standard needs is
more complicated than that.
OK template on is Collins class Iterator
Dr publicly from category basis Const.
OK so that gets us hyped up. These are
structs so that's publicly available.
It's good private data member,
no unique address tuple iterator tea
maybe consist constitute types current.
Uh, that is this and the zip you iterator
tuple iterator team may beacons current.
OK. Uh friends if you using
extended friends syntax.
Ah, let's see. Do we need that? Yes,
we do because I'm a member as a child class,
so I can access the parent classes.
Contents because I have the
same access as any other member.
But if the parent wants to access
the child classes contents we need
to declare friendship.
OK then we have context for split
Iterator constructor taking.
That duple type undercurrent under.
And that is going to be.
That even depicted.
Not actually depicted.
Uh, this is private.
Um, do we have an exposition only?
No. It's just.
Standard just assumes that we can.
Ohh I see this one.
Where is this coming from?
Where was that declared
and I just scroll over it?
Ohh, it's hiding up here.
OK, so it is mentioned in the
standards just exceptionally OK um.
As explicit iterator.
Uh, tuple iterator T?
Ah, how many times does this occur?
Can we extract this with the type def?
Every time No 5.
Ohh that's out there.
Um deco Valance.
Three is annoying enough that I
do want to ask for extraction.
Anymore would be and my usual
rule is if it's mentioned three
times and if it's lengthy then.
It's reasonable to extract.
And it Rams here, which is really annoying.
I'll suggest it. Um. This here we go.
This thing is the one that occurs, yes.
Occurs 3 times and is verbose enough to.
Causeway wrapping.
Say suggestion.
Um, extracting a? What do we want
to call this current tuple? Maybe?
Multiple.
I took that that would
be the more classic name,
but my tuple current kind of sounds weird.
At least current tuple would reinforce the.
What we're talking about.
It is my tuple because it
is the only data restoring.
I'll offer both suggestions.
My. Two Paul type def.
Are. Any other name?
I'll be too picky about the name.
Would help. Credibility. OK, suggestion.
Couple of horribleness occurs 3 times
and is verbose enough to cause wrapping.
Extracting a current tuple or my tuple type
def or any other name would help readability.
OK, otherwise just fine.
Um, we're no except if only
one no except two is a bug.
If is no throw move Constructable V of blah.
OK, because we do move it in strengthend
current, move current, OK. Public.
So iterator concept see below.
Um, but here we go.
Iterator concept is if all
reanimate access is consu types,
then random access iterator tag.
If they're all bidirectional,
then bidirectional iterator tag.
If they're all forward then forward
iterator tag, otherwise input it or tag.
OK, good. Using value type oh,
here's the value type um.
That is the type def.
If only this were up a bit, um.
No, it's different.
Oh, it's range value T, not iterator T OK,
so we can't use that type def using
value type is tuple of range value T.
Let's say here we go this here.
Of maybe constant constant view
types dot OK using different type is
common type T of range difference T
of maybe Constance continue types OK.
Default set or default?
Cons expert iterator?
So I highlight too much comps.
Expert iterator.
Taking iterator of not constant R Us, not I.
This is strengthened here.
And it requires um.
The strengthening is.
Is no through convertible V
from iterator to fu types.
That's. Us.
Convertible takes what we are and
then it's saying converting 2.
Is that the right order?
That doesn't look right. Um.
Let me let me come back to that.
What is the requirement here?
So requires is constant.
I got to be constant because I
can construct a constant rate
from non cons and convertible
2 iterator T view types. Uh.
Iterator T constant views and data.
So saying for all of the component
iterators the modifiable 1,
the iterator for the modifiable
view has to be convertible to
the iterator for constant view.
You can always add consonants,
so that's fine.
Because we're. Constructing an iterator.
We're constructing our iterator
of constant because we're const
from iterator of nonconstant.
Yes. OK, so then this is asking.
This is mirroring it. It's saying OK,
OK, I think I think this is right.
Um. Is Nothrow convertible
V Iterator T of U types?
Not not doing the maybe cons thing.
So this is actually.
The types within the RHS OK,
and can we convert those two iterator T of?
This is maybe constant, not cost.
I think this is wrong.
Because we're converting to us and
we are is cons, not not as constant.
Like essentially the the strengthening
here should substantially mirror
the requirement for convertibility,
except it's going to use this
go through convertible V is the
requirement is the requirement busted?
Did I miss that because it's
using maybe constant constant?
Standard doesn't use. Maybe cost here.
Yeah, good point. OK.
So yeah, you're right.
Requires is busted.
And then?
I'm virtually certain the
strengthening is not right.
It they they should mirror,
essentially it should be is no throw
convertible V iterator T views to
iterator T constant views because
it's not just enough that it can
be convertible like this describes
the conversion we're going to do.
Then we need to ask,
can you do that without throwing?
Um, so it needs to use the
titrate rather than the concept,
but otherwise it should be identical.
OK. Yeah, I think, I think this bug,
I'll comment on that. OK, thanks.
It's always nice to know that I'm
not just jumping in phantoms.
Um, OK uh,
currents did move RHS current uh
which will do a component wise
move of all the stuff in the tuple.
So at least that's easy.
You know,
I'd really love to have no except auto.
I'd love to have requires like if
I'm just well for an I know why the
standard at least doesn't have just
the requires of the body's well formed,
I'd really love that.
No except auto though having to spend.
I mean look,
the specification for the
constructor is like 10 times the
size of the actual implementation.
Uh,
the compiler knows whether
this stuff is going to throw.
Um,
we're definitely working around
a limitation of language here.
OK, let's comment here. Should I have?
Two comments or one comment?
Cameron's joking that that'll
be his next hackathon project.
I think probably 2 comments
because they are different.
Let's come in on the requires first.
Here I will give credit.
Uh Casey um noticed that?
Be standardized says
let's not highlight here,
let's get everything here.
Um. But uh.
Which doesn't use maybe cost?
Actually, now let me say, um,
so this you, or so the usage.
Of maybe consed here appears to be incorrect.
OK, Casey noticed that the standard he
says convertible to iterator T views,
iterator T const views and dot.
So the usage of maybe cons
here appears to be incorrect,
because that's the one missing thing. OK?
Got it. And then a comment about this here.
Um, so we think the iterator
T view types is right,
but this one should really be confused.
So and in fact. Even ignoring that
like this is maybe Constance.
Constance says maybe consent
is considered just opposite.
I noticed that. This, uh,
who should I come in on the whole thing?
You know it'd be distracting to get
the signature in there that this.
Exception specification says.
Uh, let's see. Should I just extract?
Now extract the whole iterator type.
How many angles is that to?
Uh. But uh.
Let's see. We are.
There's championed.
There's two issues here,
but one that flips the constness.
I wanna say flips.
That has the opposite oneness
of what we're actually.
Converting here.
Uh, let's see.
I'll explain because this is confusing.
This constructor is using a.
This constructor takes a non
constant iterator as the source.
To construct a constant
iterator destination, so the.
Is no throat convertible V. Uh type
trait. Is given the. Non. Alright.
Should be given. I want to avoid any
confusion about like what it should
be given versus what we actually wrote
in the source code should be given.
The non constant source
iterator first. Which it is.
Iterator TV types.
Then. Then. It should be given the
constant iterator destination.
Second, OK, I think I have explained that.
Um. OK, and this is big enough
that I really want bullet points.
1. Then two. Let's see.
This should match the requires.
Clause. Which says. Select again.
Let's grab the whole thing.
Let me explain. Um accept changing.
Except using.
Is Northrop convertible be?
Be instead of. Convertible 2. Says.
Iterator to confuse.
For the second. Argument. OK.
I noticed that this exception specification
says Iterator T may be constant,
not as constant you types.
But that has the opposite constants of
what we're actually converting here.
This constructor takes a non consideration
as the source to construct a fan.
I'm getting confused.
Let me restart.
I noticed that this exception specification
says Iterator T may be not as constant type,
but that has the opposite constants.
While we're actually converting here,
this constructor takes a non
considerate or correct as the source
to construct a consider destination.
So the is nothrow convertible.
V titrate should be given the noncom
source iterator first because we go
from two which it is iterator to view
types and then it should be given
the constant iterator destination.
Second,
bold that because that's the important bit.
OK, two. This should match
the requires clause,
except using is another convertible
V instead of convertible 2,
which says Iterator T confused
for the second argument.
I'll credit you again,
similar to what Casey noticed.
There.
OK. That one tiny little character.
Not expanding to a big comment,
but I think we got this sorted out.
Um, this sort of thing is just.
It's possible to test,
but it's really obnoxious to test.
You gotta write a lot of test support
code to validate this tiny thing.
So I wouldn't ask for test coverage here.
It's totally understandable how is missed.
I'm satisfied if the code expresses the
conversion that we're actually gonna do.
I don't think we need test coverage of this.
OK. Up the comment middle screen right now.
Yeah, you're correct.
Appears to be incorrect.
Isn't really quite true.
It's correct because we we've
constrained his consent to be true
already by the time we get here.
Yeah, it's just a little overcomplicated.
OK, good point.
Yeah, because we are.
Yeah. Requires is constant.
OK, good point. Um.
Um. We've constrained.
Say. The constraint.
Has already guaranteed
that is constant.
Is true um so using.
Maybe consist consist?
Is correct but. Overly, but unnecessary.
Unnecessarily verbose.
Yeah, that that'll work.
And now I'm wondering if maybe some of this
is overly complicated to avoid claying bugs.
With, uh, premature substitution.
Then then it should be marked as,
um, transition. Um yeah, true.
Yeah, we'll find out.
Constraint has not worried about it.
OK, the constraint has already
guaranteed that is cost is true.
So using maybe constants, constants,
correct, but unnecessarily verbose.
OK, thank you for that correction.
Ah, let's see.
I think we can get through.
Can we get through the rest of the iterator?
This iterator's big.
Uh, let's see how much we can
get through the next 5 minutes.
OK, so we got a draft. Wow.
Iterators can dereference constexpr auto.
OK, so now we're gonna pay attention
to whether things should be noticed.
Card after the constructor,
dereferencing should absolutely be noticed.
Guard context for auto operator star contest.
This is going to be strengthened. Um, OK,
so we've got a nontrivial strengthening here.
We're no except if.
This fold expression.
Is all true.
We need to be able to dereference
a stud deco Val of iterator T
maybe Const is constantly type,
so potentially apply constness to
each of our component iterators.
They all have to be.
No,
except because we return a tuple references,
so at that point we're fine.
This looks correct.
The parenthesis here is not
necessary because it's unary and
there's no other way it could bind.
I won't comment on it,
it's not wrong, and again,
this is a pretty complicated expression,
pretty complicated code.
If this were a smaller PR and this
were like the only issue I found,
I'd probably comment on it,
but this is fine.
Trying to be a little bit more easy,
going like refused.
OK, and then this is going
to return tuple transform.
Interesting, we have a stateless Lambda.
That takes. An auto ref ITER because
the tuple transform works on every
component of the tuple. Is that right?
Trying to remember, it was like,
yeah, hour ago we reviewed this.
Zip gets smallest distance,
no tuple transform. Apply to every
element that will invoke something.
That's. I powered machinery for.
It's just a Lambda invocation,
but that's fine because it's the
one that we use for users as well
on every element of the tuple.
OK, so. We use it down here.
Here duple transform Lambda
take autograf under Itter.
And we're going to return Decltype auto.
This is necessary.
So don't get any sort of
decay return Derek fitter.
On the current tuple. OK.
And then that will return?
Tuple transform should return a tuple of.
References.
Let's make sure that's right because
we're not directly naming the type here.
I think it is because the
decltype auto and we used invoke
result T tuple transform.
Returns whatever stood apply does.
Interesting. And then the tule
transform closure. Returns.
Here we go a tuple of invoke result.
So if. The Lambda that we give it
returns a reference, which it does
because it returns decltype auto of.
Dereferencing and ideally,
that's your return reference. Um.
Then we're going to get a tuple
of references. That seems right,
and if it happens to return AR value,
which you could get for an input iterator,
that'll participate in the tuple as well,
and I'm assuming without looking
that that is what this does. Yes,
this is directly translating the standards,
OK? I'm convinced that's right.
So that is,
this effects equivalent two wonderful.
And. OK, incrementing.
Not notice card because we can definitely
discard this context per iterator ref.
And then this is strengthened,
we're no except.
If this is no except,
can we call tuple foreach with essentially
what we're doing in the body here? OK.
It's too bad we can't centralize that Lambda.
Um, 2 tuple 4 each.
Ref auto ref fitter in cremator
on current return dear for this.
OK, looks good.
Um, context for void operator plus int.
This one also strengthens.
No, except if no except pre increment.
Again, we're done in parenthesis,
but it's consistent, which is good.
Val iterator.
It's us.
Uh,
why can't we just say draft this year?
We have access to drop this and um,
no, except don't we?
We we had problems like.
I'm asking because we had
problems like 12 years ago when
no exception originally occurred.
I'm virtually certain it's OK now.
Or that occur so like no
except here for this. Or not.
I'll do that. Let's do it.
Regex search no except dot star, back star.
Uh. This? OK, concepts can do that.
Yeah, when we when we're comparing to arrays.
Yeah, we can totally mention here for this.
Um, I think we should do that.
Uh. Because it is the body.
Uh, I believe we should be able to say.
No. Exceptive no except.
Of plus plus to your from this.
And pretend. Yeah.
OK, that's right.
Just do that return void.
And then post increment.
This can be the last one we look at.
Um. Sorry, not post increment.
Alright, it's the other post increment,
um, the one that is constrained
for all four it OK.
Where is that this one here?
So context for iterator again,
discardable plus int.
It's going to have requires,
but first we have a.
Constraint.
This actually occurs repeatedly.
The um.
Update this occurs below also for decrement.
Um, so this one here that requires
no except if we can pre increment?
Sure. And because we return by value
is no throw copy constructable V.
Iterator. Is confused.
Oh, that's our cost. Why does this
say iterator is constant iterator?
Um, using the injected class name? That's us.
That should just be iterator
according to our conventions.
We've access to the, UM,
the injected class name.
Even in no accepts, there should.
There should be no reason we can't use that.
How, how, how, how often did this occur?
Very rarely OK.
Uh, that's the first occurrence again in,
um, post stack. And.
This is separate because
this is in zip view itself,
so we do need to mention is cons
there though this is like Sentinel.
Yeah Sentinel is constant
needs to form iterators.
So yeah this is these two are the ones that
should just use the injected class name.
Let's see.
We should be able to use the.
Let's be fancy italics injected class name.
Under iterator here instead of.
I'm saying there's constant.
Curs. Below. Man.
Decrement one.
OK, we should be able to use the
injected class name iterator here
instead of saying iterator is
below an operator minus minus int.
Yeah. OK, that's a strengthening
and then requires clause.
All forward is constant view types dot.
We make a.
Constant auto temp that does not appear
in the standard is dry for this.
Increment DRF this return temp.
Uh, let's see.
Does that constant interfere with,
um, the return value optimization
and the move semantics stuff?
I think I've actually lost track
of whether it's, uh important.
I think we should do what the
standard says and not market cons.
That's one of our exceptions,
to apply cons to everything by default.
Is that right, Casey? That.
Uh, this local variable
should not be for this um,
post increment where we should say
where the standard says say auto temp
is this increment this return temp,
marking that as consist.
That inhibits the automatic moving and
maybe the named return value optimization.
I think it doesn't inhibit Nervo.
But yeah, definitely automatically
is going to be inhibited.
Yeah, it's not useful for some reason.
Yeah. So I think we should,
uh, admit the cons here,
despite our love of constant everywhere.
Yeah, I would rather that we didn't
constant things that we're gonna return.
Yeah, OK. For that reason.
OK, um, although. Contest is one of our.
Favorite keywords and we mark local
variables with it whenever possible.
This is a rare exception when returning.
A local variable. This can inhibit.
Automatic moving if.
The named return value optimization
doesn't activate for whatever reason.
These standard ease. Depicts.
Auto temp. And. We should use.
Uh. None.
Just skipping words we
should use non constant.
Auto here match it.
Occurs below.
OK,
although comps is one of our
favorite keywords and we mark local
variables with it whenever possible,
this is a rare exception when
returning local variable.
This can inhibit automatic moving if
the name return value optimization
doesn't activate for whatever reason.
The standard is depicts auto temp and we
should use non cost auto here to match.
It occurs below.
OK.
And we are now at time limits,
so I will.
I think submit a partial review looks like
we actually got halfway through this letter,
even though it feels like we've
haven't gotten that far a lot.
There's a lot of the logic in the iterator.
The actual view itself is pretty
small in comparison to its iterators,
because iterators are where all
the fun stuff happens.
We've already seen how it forms the
dereference of everything and compares
2 iterators by using equal or subtraction.
So it's pretty cool.
Um,
I will submit a partial review
and then come back to this later
after the tool set update and
finish reviewing so we can get
this ideally into 17-5 Preview 2,
although depending on logistics it
may or may not get into that release.
We're gonna try though. Umm, OK.
I'll submit this offline.
Um, as always, um,
thanks for watching this and we'll see
you next time on the open code reviews.